the carrasco's initial goal of adapting
a dog quickly ran into scheduling
conflicts we kept kind of putting dates
you know all Christmas or you know
summertime will be a good time for a dog
and we started construction on the house
and I just said to Aaron in the family
says when we're done we have a safe
environment for a dog we'll go ahead and
get one a local newscast Delta swift
blow to allens plans they had their
adopt a pet which I think they do once a
week with the pound comes in with an
animal that they're trying to adopt and
it happened to be Sadie Sadie was on
television rolling around and the cat
the newscaster was Pat and Sadie and my
daughter Sophia and I just started
screaming Aaron went right to the phone
she's gonna make the phone call
and that's pretty second we talked about
this right oh she just wanted to find
out and I think Alan was in a little bit
of a vulnerable state I don't know if he
wasn't quite awake yet they just went
out of control and I tried to fend off
and we said you know honey can we please
go see her can we please go see her and
he said yes and the rest is history
and so here we have a construction site
going on 24/7 there's guys here all
around the house and Sadie's over here
and she's whimpering and running and I
would say right away right away we saw
that she was fearful of me
let's say if I'm walking through the
house the dog will walk to the other
side of the room and puffs thank myself
Here I am in my own home and now I feel
like I'm the intruder it wears on you
and then let's say that if I walk in the
room and ends the room the dog will turn
on me and start barking at I was doing
everything I could he treats and moving
slowly talking in that high pitch boys
trying to be really calm you know it
gets worse and worse and I find myself
in a situation where I'm the only one at
home the dog is making a mess in the
house don't pee
[Music]
I'm asking for help I'm not getting help
and there's a riff going on I mean every
time a program comes on of yours I I
tell her say honey come here sit down
and now see what's going on and then she
gets defensive she thinks I'm
overanalyzing I try but I really think
that we need to bring in we need the dog
whisperer in a big way